亲爱的朋友们大家好,恋爱追光又和大家见面了,我想做一个专辑是《急梦》软件的这个进阶教程。
今天呢是第一集,《急梦》教学系列的第一期,咱们从零开始,大概呢十分钟左右的时间,您就可以用急梦来生成属于您的第一张AI图片。
咱们是不需要美术基础的,也不需要什么摄影摄像的设备,只要一台电脑或者手机就能够一键创作。
大家现在看到的呢,就是吉梦的主界面。
它是怎么登录呢?
我会把这个网址的链接放到说明栏当中。
登录呢,就是用抖音账号扫描就可以登录。
登录之后呢
急梦每一天都会给你60到100个积分
这个积分呢
是可以生图
也可以做视频
咱们呢
今天就是简单的来操作一下
给大家演示一下呢
它是如何生图的
登录进去之后呢
现在大家看到的就是急梦的主界面
急梦也就是即刻做梦
可以发挥你的想象力
做出各式各样的图片
大家现在看到的
它的主页上面呢
就有很多的图片
这些图片呢
也都是大家发挥自己的想象力做的
如果生成图片呢
它是有一个提示词
提示词输入到什么地方呢
就是点击图片生成
然后呢
把你想要生成图片的细节
输入到里面就可以了
要想好生成什么样的图片
比如说
一对情侣在海边
手牵手奔跑
很简单的提示词啊
一对情侣在海边
手牵手奔跑
然后图片4.0
然后16比9
高星2K
然后点击向上的箭头生成
大家会看到
左边这边有一个生成的按钮
它显示有一个任务正在生成中
然后可以点击这个去查看
它已经生成完毕了
生成之后呢
它会给你四张图片
大家看这个右边
这张图片呢
是不同的角度
这背影两个人在跑
这个不像咱们想象的那样啊
因为它没有露脸
然后点击重新编辑
加两个字
远景
现在疾梦生图都是免费的
将来不知道会不会免费
但是呢现在是免费的
大家看它又生成了四张图片我刚才写了一个远景一对情侣在海边奔跑刚才是正面招刚才咱们用的是远景
现在呢
来一个特写
一对情侣在海边手牵手奔跑
特写镜头
点击生成
它的速度应该很快的
现在是正在智能创意之中
生成完毕
哇四张都是背影
咱们再改一下
特写正面特写镜头
点击生成
正面的镜头出来了
动作非常的自然
特写镜头
这招非常的好
他现在的是欧美人
一对亚洲情侣在海边手牵手奔跑
正面特写镜头
点击生成
生成完毕了
咱们看一下亚洲情侣
在海边跑
正面特写镜头
然后还可以修改
一对亚洲情侣在海边手牵手奔跑
我刚才改了一下
手牵手奔跑
女的穿着婚纱
通常完毕
男的穿着衬衣和西裤
刚才生成的都是人物的
咱们现在生成一个卡通动画的感觉
我刚才输了一句提示词
一只橘猫正在做饭
非常的简单
还是图片生成图片4.0 16比9
高清2K
咱们现在呢改一下
把这个16比9呢改成9比16竖屏的
然后点击生成
现在的画面都变成了9比16的了
生成完毕
一只橘猫正在炒菜
现在是卡通感觉
咱们还可以给它变成一只橘猫正在做饭
后面呢写上写实风格
然后继续生成
大家看一会儿出来的图片是什么感觉的
这张图片有意思
下面还垫了一个凳子
它正在炒菜
非常的专注
生成完毕
现在是一个真的猫
但是它的动作并不完美
如果你不知道这个提示词怎么写的话
还可以利用别的智能软件
像GPT
咱们打开GPT
然后把这个一只橘猫正在做饭的写实风格呢
然后复制一下
然后打开GPT
告诉GPT
一只橘猫正在做饭写实风格
给我提示词
GPT非常的快
它的提示词已经给咱们写完了
提示词呢可以是英文的也可以是中文的
它呢给咱们的是英文的也无所谓
然后呢把提示词复制下来
粘贴到
集梦当中
然后点击
登场
看看GPT的提示词和咱们简单的写的这个提示词有什么区别马上就制作完毕出来了
这个比刚才咱们的简单的提示词要好了很多
所以呢这个提示词是非常关键的
拿着铲子在这个炉子上正在炒菜
下面的还冒着火
这是第二张
这是第三张
这个第三张的感觉更好一些
这是第四张
正在炒菜
这是卡通的
如果大家不知道怎么写这个提示词
也没有关系
咱们呢下面的这些图片
就会给你一些灵感
然后咱们选一张
这个美女的图片
然后呢
你可以点击这个做同款
下面呢
出来了一个对话框
这个文字呢
就是提示词
然后左面有一个图片生成
这个呢
是图片4.0的模型
因为它的4.0是最新的模型
然后这个是比例
比例呢
有智能
还有16比9
1比1
4比3
9比16
现在大家看到的图片是9比16
咱们呢可以给它改成16比9
下面是分辨率
有2K和超清4K
有2K已经足够了
然后点击向上的镜头
发送生成
然后呢咱们可以点击一下这个去查看
很快就生成了
咱们可以点开看一下效果
它一共是给咱四张图片
这张图片呢是不同的角度
这个呢是美女看向右边
这个呢是看向镜头
给你四张
如果说你喜欢这张呢
就可以点击下载键
就把这张图片呢下载了
刚才呢给大家介绍了如何生图
如何利用提示词来制作自己喜欢的图片
刚才呢咱们做了一张照片
那利用这个图片呢
是别的朋友呢
在网上发的这个提示词
咱们呢可以做这个通款
做通款之后呢
咱们刚才下载了一张照片
然后咱们现在呢
改变一下这个照片的风格
刚才下载的照片如何上传到
现在的这个软件当中呢
点这个图片生成
左面有一个加号
然后刚才咱们下载的图片
双击把它导入
导入之后呢
咱们现在呢是改变一下它的风格
我现在想改变一下二次元风格
别的都不用变
这个还是变成16比9图片生成模型也不用变然后点击向上的箭头让它生成咱们去看看上传图片的好处呢
就是它基本的图片不会变化
只是
就改背景
人物
姿势
表情
这样的话
就可以
人物一致性的情况之下
改变这些个元素
刚才呢
我选了一个二次元的风格
大家看一下这二次元的风格
和这个真实风格是不一样的
也是给了四张照片
有一张还拿着九
这张照片和刚才的照片
表情动作
画丝都是差不多的
刚才是二次元风格
咱们现在的这个状态不用动
然后再改成
3D动画风格
现在是3D动画的风格
未来风格
其实也是朋克风格
2D动画风格
它就是失去了3D动画的这种立体感
刚才咱们做的就是
上传一张照片作为参考照片
然后可以更改它的风格
出来不同的风格
这是3D风格
朋克
2D
微笑
大笑
沮丧哭泣
换背景时代广场
蓝天白云
森林
笔厅
海边
在海边大笑喝着酒
这个酒一直没离开手
骑猫头
骑猫头在海岸线上
人物一直没有变化
坐在汽车里
站在汽车的前面
汽车换一个颜色
骑自行车
在海边
傍晚的时候
又站在甲板上
在油轮上伸开双臂
旁边呢还是有一杯酒
好的
今天呢
主要是给大家介绍
如何在集梦当中生涂
从一开始的这个生涂
然后呢
换这个效果
不同的风格
而且呢
最后给大家做了一个
简单的一致性的一个测试
它可以改变图片的格式
还有颜色
表情
不同风格
像这种3D的
还有2D的现代风格
还有改变它的表情
微笑痛苦
还有换背景
这些都是非常基础的一些和奇梦的操作
下一期将为大家具体的来介绍
人物一致性的特点
好嘞
感谢大家的收看
如果大家对我的视频感兴趣的话
可以点击关注订阅
分享留言
感谢大家的收看
我们下一集再见